Wir Menschen verändern ständig unsere Umwelt.
Doch über eine der größten Veränderungen wird
leider gar nicht so viel geredet.Ich weiß nicht,
wie’s euch geht, aber wenn ich nachts durch die
Straßen laufe, kommt es mir manchmal taghell vor.
Schaufenster, Leuchtreklamen, Straßenlaternen
oder auch private Wohnungen. Alles ist beleuchtet…
und das ist leider nichts Gutes. Das Problem ist
sogar schon so groß, dass Astronauten unser
Licht sehr gut aus dem Weltall sehen können.
Ich spreche von Lichtverschmutzung!
Ein oft ignoriertes und irgendwie
auch dummes Problem. Denn es gibt oft ganz
simple Lösungen dafür. Aber das Gute ist:
Wir alle können helfen, das Problem
zu lösen und dabei auch noch selber
Teil der Wissenschaft werden. Wie
genau? Genau darum geht es jetzt.
Wenn wir in einer wolkenfreien Nacht zum
Himmel gucken, dann sollten wir eigentlich
tausende funkelnder Sterne sehen. Stattdessen
ist für viele von uns dort nur ein trübes,
orangefarbenes Glühen. Dieses Phänomen
nennt sich Lichtverschmutzung.
Ok, der Sternenhimmel wäre natürlich schöner
– aber noch gibt es ja kein Problem. Oder?
Oft wird das Licht nachts ja gebraucht und
manchmal sieht es auch einfach schön aus.
Aber was oft unterschätzt wird, sind die
Auswirkungen, die das nächtliche Licht auf
die Umwelt hat – sowohl auf Tiere und
Pflanzen, als auch auf uns Menschen.
Ein Fakt, den die meisten nicht kennen:
Lichtverschmutzung ist unter anderem
mitverantwortlich am Insektensterben.
Besonders nachtaktive Insekten werden
von Lichtquellen angezogen. Natürliche
Lichtquellen, wie der Mond, sorgen bei
den Tieren für Orientierung. Künstliches Licht
stört diese Orientierung aber. Sie bleiben bei
der Lichtquelle und sterben dann an Erschöpfung
oder sind einfache Beute für andere Tiere.
Ähnlich sieht es bei Meeresschildkröten
aus. Das künstliche Licht in der Nähe von
Nistgebieten führt zu einer Desorientierung
der schlüpfenden Baby-Schildkröten,
die dann auch anfälliger für Fressfeinde
sind oder den Weg zum Meer nicht finden.
Und auch Vögel leiden sehr unter der
Lichtverschmutzung. Ähnlich wie Insekten,
werden sie vom Licht angezogen und können so
die Orientierung verlieren. Außerdem stört
das Licht den Tag-Nacht-Rhytmus der Tiere,
sodass sie nicht mehr zur Ruhe kommen können.
Und auch du und ich sind Tiere: Der
Biorhythmus von Säugetieren wird
maßgeblich durch Hormone – vor allem Melatonin
– gesteuert und die wiederum werden durch Licht
beeinflusst. Zu viel künstliches Licht hemmt
die Produktion des sogenannten „Schlafhormons".
Dadurch wird die innere Uhr des Menschen gestört
und es kann zu Schlafstörungen kommen. Besonders
für junge Menschen, die nicht selbst entscheiden
können, wann sie aufwachen, ist das ein Problem.
Aber nicht nur das: der
24-Stunden-Tag-Nacht-Zyklus hat einen
Einfluss auf unsere physiologischen Prozesse. Dazu
gehören die Hormonproduktion, die Zellregulation
und andere biologische Aktivitäten. Eine Störung
dieses Zyklus kann deswegen mit verschiedenen
medizinischen Störungen beim Menschen in
Verbindung gebracht werden, darunter Depressionen,
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen,
Übergewicht und sogar Krebs.
Trotz alledem nimmt die Lichtverschmutzung
immer weiter zu. Und das ganze Licht,
das nachts die Stadt zum Tag macht,
fällt ja nicht einfach vom Himmel –
wie Sonnenlicht – sondern verbraucht natürlich
auch einiges an Energie und damit CO2. Und dabei
könnte die Lösung so einfach sein: das Licht
muss “nur” intelligenter eingesetzt werden.
Die meisten von uns schlafen nachts ja sowieso.
Das bedeutet: Ein Großteil der Beleuchtung ist
unnötig. Müssen Geschäfte wirklich nachts um halb
vier den kompletten Laden und das Schaufenster
beleuchtet haben? Müssen riesige beleuchtete
Werbetafeln die ganze Nacht über bis morgens
früh an sein? Oder müssen Straßenlaternen
in alle Richtungen leuchten? Man könnte
mit weniger *unnötigem* Licht viel Energie und
damit CO2 einsparen und das ohne großen Verzicht.
Okay, soweit so schlecht, fassen wir das mal
kurz zusammen: Lichtverschmutzung ist eigentlich
für alle blöd und oft gar nicht nötig, daher
öfter einfach mal das Licht ausschalten...cool
Doch ganz so einfach ist die Lösung
dann natürlich auch wieder nicht.
Welche Lichter sind zum Beispiel unnötig
und welche essentiell? Manche Lichter
sind ja auch für unsere Sicherheit
wichtig. Wo zieht man die Grenze?
Gut. Das Thema Lichtverschmutzung ist dann
doch etwas komplexer und genau deswegen habe
ich mit Dr. Christopher Kyba gesprochen.
Er ist Wissenschaftler und Experte auf
dem Gebiet der künstlichen Beleuchtung
und Lichtverschmutzung. Und er forscht
daran sowohl in Bochum als auch in Potsdam.
Außerdem arbeitet er gerade an einem besonderen
Projekt das vom Bundesministerium für Bildung
und Forschung gefördert wird und bei dem ihr
sogar mitmachen und helfen könnt! Wie das
geht, das stell ich euch gleich genauer vor.
Aber Chris hat mir erstmal etwas Spannendes
erzählt, was ich so noch gar nicht wusste:
Richtige Dunkelheit gibt es eigentlich gar nicht.
Dunkelheit ist eigentlich eine menschliche
Idee. Es ist nicht ein physikalische Ding.
Unser Sichtsystem reagiert auf den Kontrast,
nicht auf wie hell oder dunkel irgendwas
ist. Und das bedeutet, dass es ist oftmals der
Fall, dass mit weniger Licht man sieht besser.
Das lässt sich gut an einer
optischen Illusion veranschaulichen:
Der Schachbrett-Täuschung.Bei dieser
Illusion sollen die Felder A und B
miteinander verglichen werden. Auf den
ersten Blick sieht Feld B heller aus,
aber wenn man die beiden Felder verbindet, sieht
man, dass beide exakt die gleiche Farbe haben.
Die menschliche Wahrnehmung ist darauf
ausgerichtet, die weiße Fläche auch im
Schatten noch als weiß zu identifizieren. Deswegen
bewerten wir die Helligkeit nicht absolut, sondern
über Kontraste. Dieser Effekt kann dazu
führen, dass wir aufgrund von zu viel oder
schlecht konzipiertem Licht unsere Umgebung
dunkler wahrnehmen, als sie tatsächlich ist.
Und das ist der Grund warum es wäre möglich,
die Lichtverschmutzung zu verbessern,
weil wir brauchen nicht mehr Licht
in unserer Stadt um besser zu sehen,
wir brauchen ein besser ausgedachtes Licht.
Genau! Aber dafür müssen wir Licht noch
besser verstehen. Es fehlt noch an Forschung,
an Daten und es gibt noch eine
Menge Fragen. Zum Beispiel, wo
genau künstliche Beleuchtung wie stark eingesetzt
wird. Und genau das will das Projekt Nachtlichter
von der Nachtlicht-BüHNE jetzt ändern.
Bei dem Nachtlichter-Projekt versuchen wir
die Lichter unserer Städte zu verstehen.
Es gibt Satelliten, die jede Nacht
Aufnahmen von der Erde machen. Aber
diese Satelliten fliegen über Deutschland und
andere Orte um zwei Uhr morgens. Das bedeutet,
sie geben uns nicht einen richtigen Blick von der
Erde, wenn die meisten Leute auf der Straße sind.
Konkret bedeutet das: Es müssen Daten
gesammelt werden, darüber welche Art von
Lichtern nachts wo an sind; wie viele es
von welcher Art gibt und besonders *wie*
sich die Beleuchtung über die Nacht hinweg
verändert. Und genau da kommt ihr ins Spiel.
Denn das besondere an dem Projekt ist: Ihr könnt
Teil davon sein und der Wissenschaft helfen,
indem ihr Lichter zählt! Das nennt sich Citizen
Science und finde ich persönlich mega cool!
Ihr braucht lediglich ein Handy und im besten
Fall noch einen Laptop oder Tablet. Denn bevor
ihr richtig loslegen könnt, müsst ihr zuerst ein
ca. 20-minütiges Training absolvieren. Es geht
hier schließlich um echte Wissenschaft
und nur so kann sichergestellt werden,
dass jeder den gleichen Vorgaben folgt
und die Open Source-Daten am Ende auch
wirklich verlässlich sind. Danach kann man
die Nachtlichter-App im Browser öffnen und
sich ein öffentliches Profil erstellen. Ganz
wichtig, ihr müsst dafür eurem Browser erlauben,
auf den Standort zuzugreifen. Und auch wichtig
zu erwähnen ist, dass ihr, wenn ihr zählt,
mindestens zweimal auf eurem Straßenabschnitt die
Lichter zählen solltet. Also zu zwei verschiedenen
Uhrzeiten in derselben Nacht, denn es geht wie
gesagt auch um die Veränderung der Beleuchtungen.
Um besser zu verstehen, wie
genau das ganze funktioniert,
bin ich zusammen mit Chris nachts
in die Kölner Innenstadt gefahren,
hab das ganze einmal selbst getestet
und euch natürlich mitgenommen.
Cedric: Ok, dann erklär mir doch mal,
wie kann ich das Tutorial machen, wo
muss ich hingehen, was muss ich machen?
Chris: Man muss erstmal zur
Nachtlichtbühne.de gehen und
dann auf Nachtlichter klicken, da
gibt es einen Link zum Tutorial.
Cedric: Ok, ich habe das Tutorial
abgeschlossen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch
jetzt bist du bereit die App zu nutzen
Wir haben jetzt schon Abends,
die Sonne ist untergegangen, dann lad ich mir
jetzt mal eine App herunter würd ich sagen.
Ihr habt schon 314.000 gezählte
Lichter - 5.000 Zählungen und
7.000 Zählabschnitte. Was braucht ihr so
am besten mindestens? Was hättet ihr gerne?
Cedric: Also hoffentlich kann Team Doktor
Whatson das noch so ein bisschen erhöhen. Also,
wir stehen jetzt am Beginn unseres Abschnitts, den
wir ausgewählt haben. Ok, halben Meter weiter und
wir haben ein beleuchtetes Pizza Schild und das
lustige, es heißt sogar Pizza in eurer App….Es
ist aber kein beleuchtetes Schild, sondern ein
Leuchtschild, es ist nämlich selbstleuchtend. Ich
würd sagen es ist mittel, so eine Fernsehergröße.
Es sind zwei einzelne, die aber weiß sind.
Chris: Achtung, nicht vergessen.
Cedric: Oh, das hätte ich jetzt falsch gemacht.
Cedric:1, 2 also nochmal …dann sind wir
schon bei 8 und wir sind hier gerade mal
4 meter gelaufen. Wir haben echt viel Licht hier.
Cedric: Es geht ja doch relativ schnell,
wenn man einmal dabei ist und sich relativ
gut auskennt, wird man relativ routiniert.
Erst als ich mit der App durch die Stadt
gegangen bin, ist mir so richtig aufgefallen, wie
unglaublich viele Lichter es allein in einer
Straße gibt. Von großen Werbetafeln bis hin
zu kleinen beleuchteten Klingelschildern.
Alles erzeugt Licht und vieles davon ist
ziemlich unnötig und vermeidbar. Und das ist
nicht nur meine Meinung, sondern auch die von
Licht-Forscher Chris. Gerade die Vermeidung
von Licht wäre ein Win-Win für alle: Menschen,
Tiere, Klimaschutz und das eigene Portmonee.
Und das Gute ist, *jeder* kann was ändern!
Chris: Es gibt Millionen Entscheidungsträger
in Deutschland, die Lichter installieren oder
besitzen, wie z.B. jeder Ladenbesitzer oder
jeder die ein Haus oder Wohnung hat. Jeder
von uns kann entscheiden, ob wir die Gardine
runter bringen, später nachts oder nicht.
Und ein Projekt in Slowenien hat übrigens
gezeigt: Manchmal muss man das Licht gar
nicht ausmachen, sondern nur dimmen.
Hat visuell fast den gleich Effekt:
Aber einen riesen Impact!
Hier wieder das Thema Kontraste,
von dem Chris vorhin sprach.
Und ihr könnt wie gesagt alle bei dem Projekt
mitmachen – je mehr Daten es gibt, desto besser
kann die weitere Forschung auch Lösungen bieten!
Und dabei hat das Ganze noch echt Spaß gemacht!
Chris: Dieses Projekt ist nur möglich, wenn ganz
viele Leute mitmachen aus verscheidenen Städten
in Deutschland. Und deswegen würden wir euch sehr
gerne einladen mitzumachen. Das hilft uns enorm.
Cedric: Danke dir und danke an die
Nachtlichtbühne. Das Citizen Science Projekt wird
im Rahmen des Wissenschaftsjahres 2023 – Unser
Universum vom Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung gefördert. Macht jetzt mit, es ist der
erste Link unten in der Videobeschreibung und ihr
habt nur noch im Oktober zeit und ihr könnt hier
wirklich Teil von etwas wichtigem und gutem sein.
Danke fürs zugucken, danke an euch fürs Mitmachen
und wie immer: bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.